هل فشلت أمريكا في حماية أوكرانيا؟
وهل باتت أوكرانيا على وشك
أن تسقط بيد الدب الروسي
إن سقطت كييف؟
أمريكا تجهز سيناريوهات لخروج
زيلينسكي وتشكيل حكومة منفى.
وبينما تبحث واشنطن عن بديل لزيلنسكي،
خرج الرئيس الأوكراني يقول
أنا أحتاج إلى سلاح وليس إلى عربة نقل،،
فيما تطلب كييف الوساطة
من الجميع ومن بين الوسطاء
يوجد حلفاء موسكو الأقوياء،،، ،
صاروخ الشيطان يستمر بالظهور
والرعب يستمر لدى الغرب
من السلاح الروسي...
أوكرانيا تستجدي الغرب وبوتين
يستمر بتهديدهم والعقوبات تزداد،
وسط اتهامات بين الطرفين
لعرقلة المفاوضات فكيف سيكون
الحال كلما طال أمد الأزمة الأوكرانية؟
بينما يحاول الغرب إخراج الرئيس الأوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي إلى الخارج،
رد عليهم زيلينسكي بأنه بحاجة لسلاح
ليقاتل وليس بحاجة إلى وسيلة نقل
لتخرجه إلى الخارج...
كل ذلك يجري وسط استعدادات أمريكية،
لتجهيز حكومة منفى أوكرانية،
أو رئيس بديل لزيلنسكي في حال
تم قتله أو اعتقاله،،
فهل اقتربت الحرب من نهايتها؟
خلال ذلك أوكرانيا تجري حوارا
ديبلوماسيا مع الصين بهدف الوساطة
لإنهاء الحرب،،
ودول كتركيا والسعودية وقطر
تعرض الوساطة في الأزمة الأوكرانية..
سيطرت القوات الروسية على مدينة
برودينكا شمال غرب كييف،..
وأعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
سيطرتها بالكامل على قاعدة عسكرية،
في مقاطعة خريسون جنوبي البلاد، ..
،، أوكرانيا تطالب الغرب بمقاتلات
جوية كافية لمواصلة المقاومة،
والغرب لم يستجب لهذه الدعوات بعد،
في حين كان الناتو قد رفض قبلها إقامة
منطقة حظر جوي في أجواء أوكرانيا،،
لكن هل هناك مطارات لتستقبل الطائرات
التي سيتم رفد أوكرانيا بها؟،
وهل هناك رادارات لا تزال تعمل؟،
وهل تستطيع كييف القتال بهذه الطائرات
في ظل سيطرة جوية روسية في سماء أوكرانيا،
وفي ظل امتلاك روسيا للآلاف من الطائرات
أضافة إلى حاملات الطائرات،،
لكن الطيران الروسي لم يدخل بكامل قوته
كما تقول التقارير،
فروسيا تريد إثبات أنها مجرد عمليات عسكرية
وليست حربا شاملة،،
هذا ترك المجال للعالم لطرح سؤال مهم،
وهو هل الطيران الروسي في مرمى الدفاعات الأوكرانية؟
يقول المحللون أنه إن استمر الوضع هكذا
ولم يفعّل الروس الهجوم الجوي
بشكل كامل فسيخسر الكثير،
وسط استخدام كييف للمسيرات التركية بيرقدار
التي تخدم الأوكران بشكل كبير...
ويبدو أن هدف أوكرانيا ليس المقاتلات الجوية
بل الدفاعات الجوية ومضادات الطائرات
بحسب المحللين،
تبادل للاتهامات بين موسكو وكييف بعرقلة
وقف إطلاق النار، وفتح الممرات الآمنة
للنازحين جراء العمليات العسكرية...
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الرئاسة الروسية بيسكوف،
يحذر من أن حظر استيراد أمريكا للنفط
من موسكو قد يؤدي إلى عدم استقرار
في أسواق الطاقة العالمية، وسيترتب عليه
عواقب خطيرة
قيادة الأركان الأوكرانية:
العدو يضيق الخناق على كييف وخاركيف
ويسعى للسيطرة على محطة كانييف للطاقة.
مستشار الرئيس الأوكراني:
ألحقنا خسائر فادحة بالقوات الروسية
في 10 أيام من الحرب وسنفعل المزيد.
وسائل إعلام أوكرانية:
حالة تأهب تحسبا لغارات جوية
في تشيرنيهيف وخميلنيتسكي وتوجيهات
بدخول الملاجئ فورا .
(الأحداث والتطورات)
مفوض الأمم المتحدة لشؤون اللاجئين:
هناك أكثر من 1.5 مليون لاجئ عبروا من أوكرانيا
إلى دول الجوار في 10 أيام.
إدارة بايدن سمحت بهبوط طائرة روسية
لإعادة دبلوماسيين روس لدى الأمم المتحدة
تم طردهم بتهمة التجسس.
نيويورك تايمز عن مصادر حكومية غربية:
واشنطن وحلفاؤها يبحثون تأمين بديل لزيلنسكي
في حال مقتله أو اعتقاله.
حاملة الطائرات ترومان تتجه إلى بحر إيجه،،
تحسبا لأي تصعيد من الجانب الروسي
لإدارة المضيق التركي،،
بانتظار طلب تركي للأمريكان بالتدخل..
في مقابلة على الحدود البولندية مع نظيره الأمريكي،
قال وزير خارجية أوكرانيا
أنهم يطلبون من أمريكا طائرات وأنظمة دفاع جوية كبيرة،
لضمان سلامة أجوائها،،
ليرد الوزير الأمريكي..
بأن الدعم الغربي لأوكرانيا سيزداد
خلال الأيام المقبلة ....
بوتين: فرض قرار حظر الطيران فوق أوكرانيا
يعتبر مشاركة في أعمال عدائية ضد روسيا،
فهل يجرؤ أحدهم على فعل ذلك؟
إسرائيل تجري مباحثات سرية مع روسيا
للوساطة في الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية..
الغرب يراهن على العقوبات الاقتصادية
لزعزعة استقرار روسيا وإن لم يستطع
الأوربيون إيقاف الحرب، فهم ينتظرون
أن تنكسر ثقة الشعب الروسي ببوتين
وحكومته وبالتالي تأتي الانتفاضة من الداخل
بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي..
(الرعب الروسي)
٣٥ألف سلاح نووي غير استراتيجي
في مخازن روسيا،
وبحسب صحيفة تيلغراف البريطانية
فقد ورثت موسكو هذه الأسلحة بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي عام ١٩٩١،
وهذه الأسلحة مخبأة تحت الأرض في ١٢ مخبأ
بحسب الصحيفة البريطانية،
بينما تمتلك روسيا وأمريكا ٩٠%
من الأسلحة النووي المصرح بها في العالم،..
ففي ترتيب الدول التي تمتلك أكبر ترسانة نووية
في العالم
تأتي روسيا في المقدمة ب ٦٢٥٥ قنبلة نووية،
ثم الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ب٥٥٥٠ قنبلة نووية
بينما تبقى دول قليلة جدا لا تمتلك حتى ما يصل
إلى ألف قنبلة نووية
الجيش الأوكراني يعزز وجوده على محاور
الطرق الرئيسية بين دنيبرو – خاركيف
وبين دنيبرو – زابورجيا.
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي في مولدوفا يقول:
• الرئيس بوتين يهدد الديمقراطية وقد ورط بلده
في الحرب على أوكرانيا.
• الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا انتهاك لكل القوانين
الدولية.وهذا سبب أسرع أزمة لجوء في أوروبا
منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية..
• الكونغرس خصص 2.7 مليار دولار
لمواجهة الأزمة الإنسانية الناجمة عن الحرب
في أوكرانيا.
رئيسة مولدوفا:
• نحتاج إلى مساعدة المجتمع الدولي حتى نتمكن
من تقديم المساعدات للاجئين الأوكرانيين.
• نددنا بشدة بحرب روسيا على أوكرانيا
وطالبنا منذ البداية بوقفها واللجوء للحوار
روسيا لا تتوقف عن الهجوم وأوكراني
لا تتوانى عن الدفاع،
والعالم بين فارض للعقوبات ويبن وسيط
أو جالس في مقاعد المتفرجين، فماهوا
مصير أوكرانيا بعد ذلك؟